films finally being released how do you
feel I feel relieved and excited yeah
what's the process been like for you
it's been um so different and
interesting and cool and crazy and and
the present fans are loving the movie
and I've been in New York the last
couple days what does that mean to you
to have everybody responds a positive
it's really special I think that you
know we have been working so hard on
this film and really trying to maintain
the artistic integrity and also be you
know faithful to the fans so um I'm it's
it's really great it's great and
everyone's very passionate about the
movie why was it important for you guys
to get it you know get it right I mean
when you're dealing with two components
such as this love story and then also
this like crazy subculture that I didn't
really know anything about but it's like
so intriguing and interesting you really
want to like you have to be we had to be
very careful and um really stay true to
the fans which was important and you
know because there are so many people
who really really love this book and
there's so many bits that you know they
worship so we had to get those in but we
also wanted to make it different and
make it a real film so um that was that
was the thing what's it been like
working with jaron jamie dornan how has
it been sharing this experience with him
it's been so lovely I think that we got
really lucky um I couldn't ask for a
better person to be doing these things
with and even to be filming the movie
with he's really trustworthy and kind
and gentle and funny and like just
awesome what made Sam the perfect
director for this film
I just think that Sam is the most
wonderful person um she has she's a real
true artist she sees the world in such a
beautiful way and um she really
understood all of the underlying
components of the film and that's where
we sort of lined up and with the
emotional the emotional pole and the
comedic moments and the sexuality and
the difference in that and she really
did everything and then managed to also
make it look extraordinarily beautiful
last question what do you hope audiences
what are you most excited for them to
see in the movie um I think that people
I'm excited okay first and excited for
people to see um the sort of like
transformation that both of these
characters go through um physically and
um like oh it's fast fashion of
fashionably that's not what I mean
physically and um then also i'm excited
for people to see the negotiation scene
because i think that that shows like a
completely different side to the
characters and i'm excited for people to
see the red room because it's so
beautiful and everything is like so
intricate and special it's really they
did an incredible job with that
you